throughout the course Carolyn and I
introduced a lot of new concepts in
terminology to help you keep track of
everything we'll build a map of these
concepts often asking you to think about
how these ideas relate to one another
and where the new ideas fit into the
grand scheme of things let's get started
by writing down a few things we've
talked about already the first and
biggest concept we've introduced is
version control this refers to any
system that allows for systematic
versioning of content that is anything
that makes it easy to create store and
access different versions of the same
documents code recipes or whatever
content you're working on here are some
specific version control systems we've
talked about these are all types of
version control so we could draw lines
between each of them and the version
control node and annotate the
connections with labels like type of but
if we do that our map will soon get
cluttered with tiny annotations instead
let's use colors to indicate what type
of relationship each connection has
we'll use this colour of blue to mean
type of as you've probably gathered by
now the system we'll be focusing on is
get though we will continue mentioning
some of these others from time to time
to contrast with git using our
comparison chart the most recent concept
we've come across is the git commit this
new concept is not directly related to
version control it connects through the
git system and if we drew lines between
every second order connection our map
would quickly get out of hand some of
these other systems also involve some
similar concepts two commits but they
don't actually call them that so we'll
just keep it connected with git do you
think that this should be the same kind
of connection as the ones we already
have remember that those were type of
connections commits aren't a type of git
but rather a component so the connection
here should be a new color that
indicates a part of connection we'll use
green for that and we'll add the label
here now this time I walked you through
the process of adding items to the
concept map to give you an idea of what
we're doing with it later on you'll be
asked to decide how new items fit in for
yourself now let's go to Caroline to
find out how to view previous commits
and get